sur direct de kiev la capitale de son
pays et il vient pleurer ottawa d'en
faire davantage pour le peuple ukrainien
c'est très important pour lui de rester
en lien avec les alliés de garder ce
contact de leur entrée très étroit
monsieur zylinski et déjà fait le même
exercice auprès du parlement britannique
où il a été d'ailleurs chaleureusement
ovationné donc il devrait remettre sa
part la suite demain devant le congrès
américain au menu aujourd'hui donc il
est prévu qu à 11h15 le premier ministre
doit d'abord prennent la parole accueil
avec un discours son homologue ukrainien
il devrait annoncer aussi de nouvelles
sanctions contre une quinzaine de
personnalités russes et l'appui aussi la
proximité qui caractérise la relation
entre l'ukraine et le canada rappelons
que nous avons ici la deuxième plus
grande espérance chrétienne en
importance avec un million quatre cent
mille personnes descendante d'ukraine et
c'est d'ailleurs la troisième fois vous
savez qu'un président ukrainien reçu un
carton d'invitation pour s'adresser au
parlement canadien il ya eu dans les
années précédentes monsieur porochenko
c'était en 2014 quelques mois après
l'annexion illégale de la crimée il le
début de la guerre dans le donbass il ya
eu aussi viktor iouchtchenko ça c'était
en 2008 donc pour marquer cet événement
important mieux comprendre les enjeux
j'ai avec moi le spécialiste de
l'ukraine deux mini car elle est
professeur à l'université d'ottawa et
j'ai aussi louis blouin qui suit tout ça
avec nous depuis tôt ce matin qui va
être là tout au long de cette émission
spéciale c'est notre correspondante à
web en soirée vous de bons jours en fait
l'animal soit
sereine j'ai commencé avec vous vous
vous attendez à quoi de la part du
président craignant aujourd'hui
je m'attendre beaucoup d'émotion parce
que les grands discours c'est les mots
mais c'est surtout la façon dont le
message passe et puis
zelensky nous électrise depuis trois
semaines parce qu'il est très
authentique qui évidemment et c'est un
ancien comédien alors ils maîtrisent
très bien le vert de la communication et
puis voilà je m'attends à un grand
moment il a été remarquable dans ses
discours mais non seulement dans ses
discours dans toutes ses sorties c'est
quelqu'un qui maîtrise très très bien
lors des vidéos de la communication
modernes aujourd'hui là où on lance dans
les réseaux sociaux la des
communications très touchant on l'a même
déjà comparaître chose qui n'est pas
rien
oui mais à écouter certains c'est un
acteur mais ce qu'il fait depuis trois
semaines c'est pas c'est pas du cinéma
c'est réel c'est pour ça que le message
passe autant autant auprès de son peuple
le taux de popularité a dépassé les 90%
alors qu'avant la guerre c'était en
dessous de 40 par certains politiciens
en guise mais normal avec des opposants
et tous et puis c'est justement c'est
l'authenticité la capacité de faire
parler littéralement ses tripes ses
émotions dans un moment dans un contexte
dramatique sans précédent parce que
poutine carrément je veux détruire les
craintes veut détruire la souveraineté
de l'ukraine qu'est-ce qu'il peut gagner
avec cette communication aujourd'hui
cette allocution devant le canada
peut-être que les gains seront pas
immédiats mais d'avoir justement cette
attention dans un moment vous avez
mentionné c'est le troisième le
président ukrainien dans l'histoire
récente qui s'adresse à la nation au
parlement
mais évidemment c'est le premier c'est
le premier qu'il fait dans une situation
de guerre dans un contexte la première
guerre d'agression sur le sol européen
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale alors
lorsqu'il y à parler au parlement
britannique demain au congrès c'est ça
qui fait l'événement si unique qui nous
parle de littéralement son bunker
mais je pense qu'ils vont jouer aussi
beaucoup sur la fibre très très profonde
qui lie le canada et l'ukraine vous avez
mentionné la communauté ukrainienne la
deuxième plus grande importance mais
honnêtement c'est la première lorsqu'il
ya une communauté ukrainienne en russie
qui est démographiquement et plus
importante mais elle n'a pas pu jamais
s'organiser en raison de la répression
russe entre autres alors qu'ici au
canada c'est une communauté qui est très
organisé qui est très présente et qui
fait partie de notre histoire vous
attendez vous à ce qu'ils s'adressent
aussi directement aux descendants
d'ukrainiens au canada probablement
sûrement en fait sûrement puisque
écouter ses 130 ans d'histoire
la première migration date des années
1890 correspond essentiellement à la au
développement de l'ouest canadien et
puis il ya eu quatre grandes vagues de
migrations et la quatrième se poursuit
depuis 30 ans depuis l'indépendance
ukrainienne malheureusement et de toute
évidence s'il y en a une cinquième
maintenant avec les réfugiés le canada
va faire plus que sa part donc oui
évidemment qu'ils veulent il va en
parler
il a martelé le message et les autres
députés aussi ukrainien avec qui on a eu
l'occasion à la fois de parler mais
retenait le même message c'est à dire
cette demande d'exclusion aérienne
protéger le ciel de l'ukraine il se fait
dire non de façon systématique on
comprend le risque d' escalade qui est
derrière ça la communauté internationale
qui pour l'instant n'est pas prête à
s'engager là dedans est ce que vous vous
attendez à ce qu'il leur demande
maintenant devant les parlementaires
canadiens
oui oui
zelensky va pas cesser de leur demander
bon ce qu'ils veulent faire aujourd'hui
probablement mais écoutez il le fait
parce que la russie s'attaque au civil
c'est les bombardements indiscriminés
des villes on est au delà de la
résistance héroïque
disons le comme ça de de l'armée
ukrainienne dans les combats avec
l'armée russe les bombardements de ville
c'est pas contre l'armée ukrainienne
c'est contre la population civile alors
le cri du coeur de deux elin ski c'est
de dire il faut il faut empêcher il faut
arrêter ces crimes de guerre et crimes
contre l'humanité d'où la zone
d'exclusion aérienne d'où la tentative
d'avoir des avions de chasse le
militaire c'est pour ça qu'il le répète
mais monsieur rêve c'est justement ce
qui rend la situation si insupportable
quand on est à l'extérieur mais qu'on
est un observateur attentif de ce qui se
passe c'est à dire on ne veut pas de
civils assassinés évidemment dans un
conflit comme ça mais on se sent en même
temps coincé et impuissant oui c'est
très angoissante et mais je pourrais
dire zelensky pendant des mois avant la
guerre ne cessait de demander des armes
létales les états unis en donner un peu
mais c'est y frapper le mur avec
l'allemagne la france et le canada le
canada a refusé jusqu'à une semaine du
début de la guerre pour précisément
enfin l'argument c'était on ne veut pas
qu'il ya une escalade bon il y en a eu
une escalade de toute façon c'est la
guerre c'est la guerre d'agression
alors ce qui semblait inimaginable il ya
un mois c'est à dire
la guerre d'agression la guerre tout
azimut le bombardement des villes ben là
on y assiste impuissant c'est imaginable
puisque ces deux vins c'est devant nous
24 heures par jour avec les médias
sociaux puis la td alors lorsqu'on dit
c'est inimaginable que l'otan le canada
qui s'opérera pourrait accepter
de remettre en question la ce refus
d'une zone d'exclusion aérienne
je ne sais pas je sais pas ce qui est
inimaginable maintenant le sera
peut-être pas dans deux ou trois
semaines qui s'est alors résolu ce qui
va continuer de la demande et une
dernière question avant de passer à mon
collègue louis est ce qu'on sait tous
collectivement trompait finalement et
sur monsieur poutine et sur la situation
c'est-à-dire vous dites là on voyait
venir il ya eu une montée dramatique
dans les discours dans les attitudes
monsieur poutine à répéter des choses
qu'on a peut-être mal décoder ou mal
comprises
c'est clair c'est clair mais le message
enfin les signaux qu'on reçoit de russie
de là par des élites des élites même
ceux qui travaillent à plein temps pour
la politique étrangère dans les
instituts et tout ce que eux aussi n'ont
pas pu venir parce que c'était
inimaginable c'est une chose de
d'intervenir au donbass et peut-être
d'étendre la guerre ou d'une base
puisque c'était le tiers du territoire
puis d'en faire une guerre dans tout le
territoire mais d'y aller avec une
guerre tous azimuts comme ça c'est on ne
l'a pas vu venir on aurait dû et puis ça
avec conséquence évidemment extrêmement
majeur pour la suite des choses et oui
on n'a pas terminé d'en parler des
conséquences parce que bien sûr il ya
les civils bien sûr il ya cette
agression terrible mais après ça il va y
avoir toutes ses répercussions aussi
même sur l'alimentation mondiale parce
qu'on parle ici de l'ukraine qui est
aussi un grenier pour le monde des pays
qui vont souffrir par la suite on aura
l'occasion de revenir sur ce outre ces
aspects là mais là je vais aller voir
louis qu'on va retrouver justement
d'employés du parlement à ottawa alors
les parlementaires sont en train de se
diriger vers la chambre comme tel pour
se préparer à écouter ses discours ouais
absolument on a vu beaucoup de députés
est aussi des sénateurs passé ils ont de
la place à l'intérieur et des chaises
qui ont été ajoutés il faut comprendre
que tout le monde ou si aujourd'hui
porte ce fameux petit ruban bleu et
jaune à la boutonnière symbole de
solidarité puis c'est ça cet exercice là
dans le fond c'est pour les
parlementaires de pouvoir exprimer eux
aussi leur solidarité démonstration
d'unité aussi du parlement canadien ce
matin avec ce discourt monsieur trudeau
qui va prendre la parole en premier
julie a pas compter deux heures quinze
environ allocution il commence ensuite
la parole à monsieur zelensky si on se
fie à son allocution au parlement
britannique la semaine dernière on pense
que ça devrait durer une dizaine de
minutes on comprend que monsieur
zelensky il ya des questions de sécurité
peut pas rester devant sa caméra de
manière très très très longue parce
qu'on le sait qu'il est ciblé il est
suivi et c'est alors une dizaine de
minutes selon ce qu'on nous dit ensuite
président du sénat qui prendra la parole
quelques minutes président de la chambre
des communes et ensuite c'est là qu'on
entendra la chef par intérim du parti
conservateur candice bergen suivi d'
yves françois blanchet du bloc jaune
meeting du npd et il habite mais qui va
représenter le parti vert tout ça
devrait durer à peu près une heure un
moment qui est oui très symbolique je
dirais même peut-être historique parce
que c'est rare qu'on a vu un président
comme ça un chef d'état ou de
gouvernement alors que son pays est en
pleine guerre venir prononcer un
discours comme celui là son prédécesseur
à monsieur hinse qui monsieur porochenko
est telle en 2014 tout de suite après
l'annexion de la crimée il avait fait un
discours et à ce moment là les v10 on se
bat pour notre indépendance mais dans
quelques années plus tard son successeur
lui arrive ici alors que le gouvernement
craignait se bat pour la survie
carrément de l'état ukrainien alors
c'est énorme il ya des vies de civils on
sait qu'ils ont été perdus déjà alors
c'est un moment très symbolique ou 6 po
les députés d'origine ukrainienne y en a
ici mais aussi tous les canadiens
d'origine ukrainienne des canadiens de
manière plus générale avec cette
diaspora très important que l'on connaît
effectivement canada et le canada ne
devrait pas le recevoir les mains vides
des gens aujourd'hui non non on annoncé
de nouvelles sanctions
quinze personnes qui s'ajoutent à la
liste des sanctions canadiennes ce sont
des responsables russes qui ont selon
lui ce que dit gouvernement et je sais
est permis ou soutenu l'invasion de
l'ukraine alors que 15 personnes qui
s'ajoutent on est quand même bien loin
des demandes de monsieur zelensky vous
l'avez évoqué un petit peu plus tôt
cette exclusion aérienne pour protéger
le ciel ukrainien quand il était devant
les parlementaires britanniques la
semaine dernière il a fait d'autres
demandent aussi de peu plus d'être
humanitaire plus d'armes létales ou 6
mai il avait réclamé aussi que la russie
soit désigné comme un état terroriste
alors c'est intéressant on verra s'il va
faire cette demande là ils cherchent des
symboles aussi monsieur céline ce qui on
le sait alors on verra bien où il ira
avec ça monsieur trudeau effectivement
n'oubliez pas l'accueillir les mains
vides avec ces sanctions de plus
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il avait gardé
son dans sa manche sachant qu'il allait
prendre la parole on va suivre ça tu
mets ta il faudra voir quelle sera la
proche canada pour la suite des choses
qui à ce programme de voyage d'urgence
pour accueillir des ukrainiens au canada
qui va entrer en vigueur le 17 mars la
ministre des affaires étrangères l'a
confirmé tout à l'heure alors à quelle
vitesse on est en mesure d'accueillir
ces ukrainiens au canada quel sera votre
capacité de traitement des demandes dans
les pays limitrophes à l'ukraine tous
ces réfugiés se rendre ça je voudrais
que c'est les gros point d'interrogation
qui demeure est aussi est-ce qu'on va
organiser des vols des vols est-ce qu'on
va nolisé des avions pour amener des
soyez comme ça ici au canada ça c'est
encore des questions qui restent en
suspens vous avez eu l'occasion dans le
courant d'avant midi louis de parler
avec des représentants des partis
d'opposition il ya quand même une
certaine unité dans la vision de tous
les partis derrière le gouvernement
on sent pas de fausses notes ici non ils
comprennent aussi parce que des demandes
de monsieur céline ski c'est cette
exclusion aérienne mais tout le monde
est bien conscient que si des forces de
l'otan commencent à s'en prendre à des
avions russes par exemple dans le ciel
ukrainienne alayan ligne qui est
franchie à madame joly parlais tantôt de
cette ligne rouge on ne veut pas que
tout ça devienne un troisième conflit
mondial alors tous les partis à gracieux
à qui on a parlé ce matin nous disent
c'est vrai il faut faire attention il
faut éviter une escalade supplémentaire
un appui je vous dirai à ces sanctions
économiques coordonnées depuis quelques
jours peut-être qui manque justement le
blog qui demande ses vols pour évacuer
les ukrainiens ils veulent avoir plus de
réponses sur combien et quand on va
pouvoir recevoir ces ukrainiens au
canada qui veulent trouver refuge et
puis l'autre question qui est soulevée
par le parti conservateur c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'on peut expulser cet
ambassadeur russe il toujours en
fonction au canada
ce que l'on comprend selon les sources à
qui on parle au ministère des affaires
étrangères du canada c'est que on veut
éviter que l'ambassadrice canadienne en
russie elle soit en par mesure de
représailles
expulsé et sans doute que cette dame qui
est là-bas a accès à des informations
qui sont très importantes pour le
gouvernement canadien alors on veut sans
doute éviter de se priver de cette
oreille sur le terrain si vous permettez
en russie pour être capable d'avoir des
informations sur les derniers
développements à voir ce canal de
communication sans doute ouvert pour
laisser place à cette négociation pas
réagi mathieu à rennes justement à ce
dernier volet de notre discussion
monsieur orel effectivement qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous de ce dossier-là
de l'ambassadeur russe qui est toujours
ici au canada et pour l'instant la
volonté du canada de de lui permettre de
rester ici
mais ça a l'air est ce que vous
m'entendez pardon pardon oui qu'est ce
que vous en pensez justement de cette
décision du canada de maintenir les
canaux ouverts finalement avec la russie
maintenir ici la permission de
l'ambassadeur russe de rester sur le
territoire canadien bah écoutez
je pense pas qu'il faut briser les liens
diplomatiques
mais même en situation de guerre comme
ça tout même la russie pas en guerre
contre le canada la réussite en guerre
contre l'ukraine et l'ukraine est en
dialogue avec la russie même s'il faut
être très réaliste
quant aux possibilités de règlement a
cours à court terme alors c'est très
important de maintenir les canaux
ouverts oui parce que ça aurait quoi
comme conséquence effectivement si on
expulse et parce que certains partis le
demande de louis ne le faisait nous en
faisant un compte-rendu parti
conservateur anton qui soulève des
questions là-dessus quelles conséquences
ça aurait de dire mais c'est terminé là
vous vous quittez vous ambassadeur de
russie
peut écouter sur les conséquences
justement c'est que le canada à ce
moment là absolument aucun aucune façon
officielle de communiquer avec la russie
sur ce dossier là ou sur d'autres
dossiers parce que c'est pas évidemment
le seul dossier c'est le dossier de très
loin le plus fondamental mais il y en a
d'autres lorsque la question de
l'article entre autres et
donc c c'est seulement quand situation
de guerre si le canada est carrément en
guerre contre la russie comme à l'époque
notre la deuxième guerre mondiale que
les relations diplomatiques sont coupées
j'aimerais que vous nous parlez aussi le
désespéré un chrétienne qui est déjà ici
on sait que bien des gens qui s'activent
en levant la main en disant moi je
serais prêt à recevoir des réfugiés de
mon pays d'origine ou du pays de mes
parents quel poids ils ont à votre avis
sur les décisions actuellement et le
positionnement actuel du gouvernement
dans ce conflit avec la russie
je pense que quand j'ai mentionné plus
tôt que c'était la commune de la
diaspora la plus importante des sports
et ukrainiens ne plus importantes au
monde
c'est justement à raison non seulement
de l'histoire mais aussi de son propre
politique qui n'a cessé d'augmenter en
fait depuis vingt ans il y avait eu la
révolution orange avec iouchtchenko en
2004 et puis bon maidan l'annexion de
l'exprimer la guerre john bass
il ya une particularité dans notre
échiquier politique où les élections
sont tellement serrés on a beaucoup
maintenant d'un gouvernement minoritaire
le poids électoral de la communauté
canado ukrainienne et est important
peut-être même dans une douzaine de
circonscriptions
ça
fait en sorte qu'en fait il ya une
espèce de consensus entre les grands
partis politiques qui s'adaptent pas de
déclenchement de la gare mais sa balle
je dirais d'une vingtaine d'années les
conservateurs les libéraux leur dit et
même le bloc dont il ya cette
unité en fait d'être plus plus pro
ukrainien plutôt que de chercher un
terrain d'entente entre la russie et
l'ukraine ce qui était la dynamique pour
donner un exemple de la politique
allemand on enfin au moins jusqu'au
déclenchement de la guerre whisky parce
qu lire je venais halles ou de loin qui
deux jours au parlement louis mais c'est
que la ministre vice première ministre
en fait madame fulin elle-même est de
descendance ukrainienne alors ça colore
peut aussi l'intervention canadienne
elle parle lui craignait on l'a vu
d'ailleurs s'adresser à la diaspora
parler dans sa langue d'origine de la
langue de ses parents finalement il
serait intéressant de voir à quel point
justin trudeau a laissé de l'espace adam
freeland aussi j'ai très bien qui a pas
mieux informé qu'elle sur cette crise là
elle a beaucoup travaillé là dessus elle
a fait des études même quand elle était
en russie elle même à ce moment là alors
elle connaît très bien ce milieu là elle
se fait un peu le porte étendard d'une
certaine façon de la communauté
ukrainienne également alors c'est clair
que madame madame fui l'inde a joué un
rôle central dans tout ça on sait que
plus ça lui fait pas mal de choses dans
son assiette actuellement et je pensais
que
fectivement alors évidemment c'est très
solennelle très officielle comme on l'a
dit on écoute tout de suite ensemble
monsieur harel louis on se retrouve
après
qu'ils ont fait en sorte qu'il soit
possible pour nous d'écouter le
président erin ce qu'ils souhaitent à
partir d'ici à la chaume souhaitent à
partir une grogne en vidéo monsieur le
ministre
je vais suspects merci monsieur le
président amis et collègues
bonjour et merci d'être ici aujourd'hui
pour accueillir un dirigeant courageux
et exceptionnel
président céline ce qui au nom des
parlementaires et de tous les canadiens
j'ai l'honneur de vous accueillir ici en
cette chambre
monsieur le président volodymyr vous
êtes un ami
les canadiens et les ukrainiens sont
amis
et le sont depuis longtemps
nos peuples ont une histoire commune
au début du xxème siècle une grande
vague d'ukrainiens a immigré au canada
la plupart d'entre eux se sont installés
dans les prairies canadiennes
ils ont travaillé la terre ils ont
construit des églises qui se distinguent
par leur magnifique flèche et ils ont
aidé à façonner le canada de nombreuses
façons quand aujourd'hui
1.4 million de canadiens d'origine
ukrainienne ce qui constitue la deuxième
plus grande diaspora ukrainienne au
monde que ce soit en tant qu'agriculteur
scientifiques leaders communautaires
athlètes ou travailleurs de première
ligne les canadiens d'origine
ukrainienne continue d'apporter une
immense contribution à notre pays mais
l'amitié entre le canada et l'ukraine ne
repose pas seulement sur cette histoire
commune elle repose aussi sur nos
valeurs communes
voilà des miens depuis les années que je
vous connais j'ai toujours considéré que
vous étiez un champion de la démocratie
et maintenant les démocraties par tout
au monde sont chanceux de vous avoir
comme champions
[Applaudissements]
jochen votre courage et le courage de
votre peuple nous inspire tous vous
défendez le droit des ukrainiens de
choisir leur propre avenir et ce faisant
vous défendez les valeurs
que sont les piliers deux qui sont les
piliers de tous les pays libre et
démocratique
liberté droits de la personne justice
vérité
règne du droit
autant de valeurs pour lesquelles vous
risquez votre vie alors que vous
combattez pour l'ukraine et les
ukrainiens mais au-delà de cela vous
inspire également les démocraties et les
lits chef démocratique par tout le monde
d'être plus courageux plus unie
et de se battre encore plus forte pour
ce en quoi ils le croient vous ne vous
nous rappeler que les amis sont toujours
plus forts ensemble
avec nos alliés et partenaires nous
imposons des sanctions accablante sur
poutine et ses appuis en russie en
belarus afin qu'ils soient responsables
de leurs actions aujourd'hui avec nos
partenaires de l'union européenne je
puisse annoncer que nous avons imposé de
nouvelles sanctions très lourdes sur
quinze nouveaux représentants réussi
compris des représentants des élites
militaires et du gouvernement complice
dans cette guerre illégale vers
l'ukraine en lui fournissant de
l'équipement militaire ainsi que de
l'aide financière et humanitaire et on
va être là pour aider à rebâtir une fois
que l'agresseur sera repoussée
in canada au canada
nous aimons encourager le plus petit
nous croyons que lorsqu'une cause est
juste et bonne elle gagnera toujours peu
importe la taille de son adversaire
ce qui ne veut pas dire que ce sera
facile
les ukrainiens avaient déjà un coût
humain incalculables
cette guerre illégale et inutile est une
grave erreur de la part de poutine qui
doit s'arrêter maintenant
[Applaudissements]
le mépris flagrant de vladimir poutine
pour la vie humaine est absolument
inacceptable
le canada continue d'exiger que la
russie 16 de cibler les civils et mettre
fin à cette guerre
injustifiable
ukrainien artem les ukrainiens
défi l'autoritarisme yanis mme et les
parlementaires unis en cette chambre ici
aujourd'hui est vraiment tous les
canadiens sont unies avec vous vous
pouvez compter sur nous comme ami vous
pouvez compter sur notre appui
indéfectible
et maintenant chez le grand privilège de
vous présenter le président de l'ukraine
notre ami volodymyr zelensky
merci beaucoup
mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le président monsieur premier
ministre cherche juste un
nombre du gouvernement membres
parlementaires
distingués invités amis avant de
commencer j'aimerais que vous compreniez
mes sentiments et les sentiments les
émotions de tous les ukrainiens
dans la mesure du possible
nos sentiments nos émotions au cours des
20 derniers jours 20 jours d'une
agression sans précédent de la part de
la fédération russe après huit années de
combats dans la région du donbass pouvez
vous imaginer
imaginez qu'à 4 heures du matin vous
entendiez des explosions ont des
bombardements des explosions massives
pouvez vous imaginer
entendre cela vous et vos enfants
entendre ces explosions ce pilonnage des
aéroports de l'aéroport d'ottawa a
imaginé
le bombardement de vauville pouvez vous
l'imaginer
des missiles
tombent
et vos enfants vous demande que se
passe-t-il
vous observez le pilonnage des
infrastructures
et vous savez combien de personnes sont
déjà mortes imaginez comment expliquer
cela à vos enfants
comment expliquer cette agression sans
précédent massive
vous savez que ça peut annihiler
détruire votre état vous savez que c'est
une guerre pour nous soumettre et au
deuxième jour de la guerre vous
recevez un avis un avis
que de l'équipement militaire entre dans
votre pays qui traversent la frontière
qu'ils se rendent vers des villes
des villes sont assiégées
encerclé
imaginez le bombardement de quartiers
résidentiels
d'école
la destruction de garderie dans la vie
de soumis aux tirs cas également
ça s'est produit imaginez
le fait que vancouver soit assiégé
imaginer les résidents de cette ville
c'est exactement la situation
dans laquelle se trouve la ville de
mario paul
il n'y a plus d'électricité d'eau aucune
moyens de communication ils n'ont
presque plus rien à manger bien plus
d'eau
on cherche un refuge dans les abris anti
bandes cher justin
estimé invités imaginez que je vous
recevez des
statistiques sur le nombre de victimes
des enfants des femmes
vous avez entendu les parler des
bombardements quatre-vingt dix sept
enfants sont morts
depuis début de la guerre imaginez la
tour du cn à toronto qui donnait
imaginer qu'elles soient frappés par des
bombes russe
bien tendu je ne souhaite la personne
mais c'est notre réalité c'est la
réalité avec laquelle nous vivons nous
savons que les bombardements
continuerons nous avons une place de la
liberté dans la ville de kharkiv
il y à babi yar également à kiev c'est
là où des victimes de l'holocauste ont
été enterrés ça a été bombardée par les
forces russes
imaginez
des installations canadiennes pilonné
bombardé comme les nôtres comme nos
immeubles non c'est
imaginer
les victimes des familles sont décédés
chaque nuit est une nuit horrible les
forces russes bombarde
de chars d'assaut
il le frappe des infrastructures civiles
il le frappe des immeubles civils
imaginez un incendie dans une usine
nucléaire c'est exactement ce qui s'est
produit dans notre pays
chaque
ville est touchée ils tirent sur les
le drapeau ukrainien je sais que vous
soutenez l'ukraine nous sommes alliés
amis avec mais j'aimerais que vous
compreniez et j'aimerais que vous
ressentiez ce que nous ressentons tous
les jours nous voulons vivre
nous voulons gagner être victorieux nous
souhaitons vaincre pour vivre
imaginez
lorsque vous appelez vos amis
nous demandons de créer une zone
d'exclusion
aérienne
il faut arrêter les bombardements les
bombardements combien domicile
et d'attac doit voir ou boire lieu avant
de de prendre des mesures
je comprends que vous exprimiez votre
grande préoccupation lorsque nous
parlons à nos partenaires ils nous
disent de tenir bon de tenir bon encore
un peu
on parle de désescalade
on parle de désamorcer
cette crise
on
soutiendra les rations à devenir membre
de l'otan mais on n'entend pas de
réponse claire
on ne voit pas nous ne voyons pas les
choses qui s impose qu'ils sont claires
il faut répondre il faut que nos amis
répandent à l'action comme ça a été le
cas depuis huit ans
je sais que vous êtes conscients de la
réalité je m'adresse à tous le canada
a toujours été un homme inébranlable
dans son soutien envers l'ukraine vous
êtes et vous avez été un allié alors
fiable pour les ukrainiens et l'ukraine
je suis convaincu que cela continuera
vous avez offert votre assistance votre
aide
est très tôt nous vous nous avez fourni
de l'équipement militaire de l'aide
humanitaire
vous avez imposé des sanctions sévères
nous observons malheureusement que cela
n'a pas permis d'arrêter la guerre vous
voyez que karkhov car qu'il veut marier
au paul ne sont pas protégés comme
vauville leçon edmonton vancouver
vous voyez maintenant que qui avait
bombardé y vante que francisque
franquiste et
attaquer notre pays
était a toujours été pacifiques et que
vous ne payez pilonné et tout ce que je
souhaite dire c'est qu'on doit faire
davantage pour stopper la russie pour
protéger l'ukraine et protéger l'europe
de la menace russe ils détruisent tous
les écoles les complexes
commémoratif les hôpitaux les maternités
et développement des ide résidentiel ils
ont tué 97 enfants on ne demande pas
grand chose aux demandes de la justice
soutient qui ne cédera à vaincre à
sauver des vies à sauver le monde et le
canada et
les chefs de file nous aident et
j'espère que d'autres emboîteront le pas
nous demandons davantage nous vous
exhortons d'avant dedans de nous
soutenir davantage de nous souvenir
soutenir dans nos efforts et nous
remercions tous les amis des amis de
l'ukraine
les amis de la vérité
il faut bien comprendre à quel point il
est important de fermer notre espace
aérien
contre les aéronefs heureuse se créer
une zone d'exclusion aérienne j'espère
que vous comprenez que vous pourrez
accroître vos espoirs vos sanctions afin
que la russie n'obtiennent aucun dollars
pour financer leur effort de guerre
les entités commerciales ne devrait pas
donc opérer en russie comme vous le
savez très bien
vous savez que la taxe sur le crâne
cette offensive est une façon de
détruire le peuple ukrainien c'est
l'objectif principal de cette
intervention et c'est une guerre contre
les ukrainiens que nous observons
c'est une tentative de détruire tout ce
que nous avons construit entendu
craignant une atteinte à notre avenir à
notre nation à ce que nous sommes vous
canadien vous connaissez très bien
tout cela c'est pourquoi je vous exhorte
n'arrêtait pas vos efforts
prolongés vos efforts pour la paix pour
que la paix revienne dans notre pays
pacifique je sais que vous pouvez le
faire vous pouvez continuer à nous
soutenir
nous ne faisons partie d'une coalition
anti guerre et je sais qu ensemble de
concert nous pourrons atteindre ces
résultats
je demande également à la diaspora qui
craignaient
canada
il s'agit de moments historiques nous
avons besoin de votre soutien de votre
soutien concret
et nous espérons qu'avec vos efforts
concrets vous pourrez contribuer à cette
histoire ukrainienne qui s'écrit
rappelez vous
qu'il s'agit
de l'histoire c'est l'histoire de
l'ukraine qui s'écrit il nous souhaitons
voir la paix vivre en paix
et donc je remercie tous les
parlementaires présents aujourd'hui
merci à tous les citoyens canadiens
je suis très reconnaissant envers vous
justin également
je remercie les canadiens
je suis confiant qu'ensemble nous
pourrons surmonter
cette épreuve nous serons vainqueur
gloire à l'ukraine et merci au canada
[Applaudissements]
thank you mister président merci
monsieur le président j'ai vite
alors voilà les applaudissements nourris
une occasion pour les parlementaires
canadiens de démontrer leur appui leur
soutien et leur amitié aussi à l'ukraine
à la suite de cette allocution du
président ukrainien à l'option dont j'ai
parlé avec mes deux invités louis blouin
est avec moi et demi car l aussie
specialists d'ukraine politologue est
avec moi aussi monsieur orange a
commencé avec vous c'est très fort à la
façon dont il a commencé son discours en
disant je vous demande d'imaginer ce
qu'est notre réalité est là il s'est mis
à décliner à décrire les bombardements
qu'est ce qu'on dit à ses enfants il ya
des morts et à faire des comparaisons
avec les villes canadiennes ai dit vous
savez par exemple marie paule c'est
comme si la ville de vancouver étaient
attaqués dont qu'il cherchait vraiment à
créer un sauna à renforcer finalement ce
sentiment très très fort des gens entre
les canadiens les ukrainiens absolument
mais sa grande force c'est d'être
capable de raconter la réalité quoi
raconter des histoires mais des
histoires réelles il nous disait dansant
dans son allocution je voudrais que vous
ressentiez ce que nous ressentons
et je pense qu'il le fait de façon très
très émouvante en fait surtout lorsque
mais on parle de garderie on parle
d'enfants en fait attaqué des hôpitaux
etc c'est perrin c'est la réalité
actuellement c'est une guerre contre la
population
comment vous le recevez ce discours
monsieur r elle vous qui êtes un expert
de l'ukraine qui connaissait bien ce
pays qui connaissait aussi les
ressortissants qui sont dit si justement
comment vous le recevez personnellement
personnellement ou en tant qu'expert il
valait 2 bah écoutez personnellement
évidemment c'est très dur pour
comment dire âge tout ce qu'on vit là
depuis trois semaines quand je dis nous
c'est les canadiens mais
particulièrement la communauté
ukrainienne certains d'entre nous qui
sont dans les études ukrainiens nous
mêmes les études russes c'est la
catastrophe la dent pour les
spécialistes de la russie de voir
cette guerre de destruction alors en
fait zielinski c'est comme
c'est comme en france un tonique c'est
comme quelques c'est en fait lorsqu'on
l'entend parler c
c'est inspirant dans toute cette
destruction
le temps est jamais hargneux le temps il
y a pas eu de menace par rapport à la
russie ou par rapport au peuple russe
qui malheureusement les sondages donnent
encore 60% au moins 2 2 puis à poutine
et cetera c'est c'est la grande force
des landes ski d'être capable d'inspirer
à la fois son peuple mais aussi la
communauté internationale donc nous les
canadiens donc en écoutant le discours
là ce matin
on s'en inspirer même si tout va mal
ce qu'il dit là je vais enchaîner avec
loin quand il a dit on vous remercie
vous canadien pour ce que vous faites
pour nous mais ce n'est pas si ça n'a
pas mis fin à la guerre il est revenu de
l'avant encore avec l'exclusion le
d'espacés aériens ouais absolument le
sujet des skis qui a écouté nous voulons
vivre nous voulons vaincre il faut des
efforts supplémentaires il a salué cette
cette amitié entre le canada ici que le
canada est derrière lui la remercie
justin trudeau personnellement mais il a
réitéré trois demandes essentiellement
et il faut continuer avec cette pression
de sanctions économiques
jean nouvel qui ont été ajoutées
aujourd'hui je vous le rappelle mais
surtout il nous faut cette exclusion
aérienne
il faut que les pays de l'otan dit il
protège le ciel de l'ukraine pour mettre
fin à ces terribles bombardements qui la
décrit pendant son discours il ça nous
prend ça on va continuer de le demander
il sait bien de savoir que vous êtes
solidaires que vous êtes derrière nous
mais il faut aller encore plus loin
l'autre demande si cette demande
d'adhésion à l'otan monsieur hinse qui
le demandent depuis des années déjà mais
il réitère publiquement parce que sans
ça le en raison de cette clause du
cinquième article de l'otan ben si le
grain ne faisait partie de cette
alliance est bien là les autres pays
serait forcé de venir à sa défense c'est
pas le cas on comprend bien que les pays
occidentaux veulent éviter de traverser
cette ligne rouge de provoquer un
troisième conflit mondial qui est une
escalade mais lui réitère cette demande
là il dit il faut que ça cesse et c'est
pour ça qu'il est allé de son message
tellement fort pour il faut que ça
résonne imaginez-vous l'aéroport
d'ottawa bombardé edmonton vancouver il
essaie vraiment de créer une connexion
avec le peuple canadien les
parlementaires ou si il faut comprendre
qu il s'est aussi adressé à la diaspora
ukrainienne au canada il a dû en avoir
besoin de vous parce qu'on sait que
notamment ya sept accueillent des
ukrainiens qui va se faire au cours des
prochains jours voire prochaines
semaines des gens qui vont venir ici
temporairement alors il en appelle aussi
à ses nombreux canadiens d'origine
ukrainienne ici mon pays et on a
maintenant d'autres discours là devant
nous alors président de la chambre par
la suite président du sénat et ensuite
ce sera au tour des partis d'opposition
qu'on ira écouter aussi chacun leur tour
ils vont prononcer une allocution à
monsieur harel comme entendez monsieur
zelensky revenir de l'avant avec cette
demande d'être membre de l'otan est-ce
que c'est réaliste est ce que c'est
quelque chose de possible et les
observateurs disent hausse s'était
compromis qui va devoir faire ça doit
même faire partie des négociations
actuellement avec la russie c'est pas
quelque chose qui va pouvoir se réaliser
vous en pensez quoi vous
écoutez je peux répondre d'abord de
façon générale ce qui semblait
irréaliste ya un mois est devenu
réaliste c'est à dire une guerre
d'agression en ukraine sur le sol
européen
les crimes contre la paix des crimes
contre l'humanité mais l'agression pour
détruire un pays on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale qui n
a pas été bombardée depuis 1944 fait
soixante dix huit ans alors ce qui
semble irréaliste et maintenant réaliste
la paire de l' escalade la peur de la
troisième guerre mondiale et les réelles
évidemment on comprend pourquoi le temps
le canada en tant que membre de l'otan
et très prudent sur cette question de
zone d'exclusion aérienne
mais écoutez on voit des images
insoutenables de mario paul ii a requis
fin où il ya 400 âmes de tours
d'habitation qui ont été détruites on
parle là des civils
si le conflit le conflit si la guerre la
guerre d'agression
continue d'empirer et puis on assiste en
temps réel à la télé et en temps réel
sur toutes les plateformes maintenant de
médias sociaux
aux bombardements de quais
littéralement millénaire je suis pas
convaincu à 100% que l'otan la
communauté internationale le canada les
etats-unis
vont peut-être changer de position la
destruction de la capitale on veut pas
évidemment on voudrait qu'un cessez le
feu demain matin mais malheureusement on
assiste à cette guerre cette guerre
contre les civils cette guerre de
terreur en fait main sur elle je vous
interrompre là dessus la chef actuelle
par intérim du parti conservateur bergen
est en train de prendre la parole on va
l'écouter tout ce président il indiqué
permettez moi d'exprimer personnellement
mon admiration pour votre courage et
votre leadership
en cette époque critique de l'histoire
de l'ukraine votre leadership est très
rare monsieur le président et il nous
inspire tous nous les élus vous êtes le
leader de l'ukraine pension pendant
cette période critique et nous sommes
en admiration de chef dans cette folle
contre votre pays et votre défense de la
démocratie les oppositions official et
aux côtés du le game center de voix nous
allons également présentes présence
pressée complète pour vous aider et oui
parce que les ukrainiens
médias les images que nous voyons de
l'ukraine comme vous venez de les
décrire nous crève le coeur ils sont
très douloureuses avoir des familles
réfugiées dans des abris anti bombes les
ruines d'hôpitaux et de maternité les
vieux qui cherche secours et sécurité
mais on y trouve également une certaine
inspiration
alors que des gens ordinaires des hommes
des femmes de tous âges défendre leur
patrie nous sommes témoins de la force
et de la défiance des ukrainiens qui
défendent leur liberté indépendance et
souveraineté
les ukrainiens ne ce ne ne lutte pas
tout simplement pour se défend de même
nom ils défendent toute l'europe car la
tacc de poutine contre l'ukraine est une
attaque contre nous tous c'est l'un ne
sont que nous a enseigné l'histoire et
que nous nous devons nous ne pouvons pas
faire abstraction
[Applaudissements]
voir et c'est pourquoi nous devons aider
le peuple ukrainien
de toutes les façons possibles le canada
compte le plus grand nombre de personnes
de descendance ukrainienne en dehors de
l'ukraine et de la russie pendant plus
d'un siècle is on enrichit nos
communautés et notre cumul culture
surtout dans les prairies canadiennes là
d'où je viens le canada et le manitoba
surtout
ont des liens étroits avec l'ukraine est
maintenant presque 1,4 mucret niakhène
canadien ukrainien regarde ces images
leur âme et leur coeur
espère et prie pour leur pays et leurs
ancêtres cette guerre d'agression
patente révèle vladimir poutine sous son
pire jour
un prédateur violent qui n'a aucun égard
pour la vie humaine où les souffrances
il a franchi deux lignes qui après deux
guerres mondiales nous pensions ne
pouvait il ne serait plus jamais franchi
et qui assurent la sécurité de 1945
chaque jour ils continuent de mentir et
de tuer des innocents des personnes
vulnérables y compris des femmes et des
enfants ils craignent haine et ce
faisant et ils continuent de menacer le
monde disant que s'il
n'a pas gain de cause il
s'en remettra aux pires extrémités il
doit être traduit en justice
il doit être tenu responsable de ses
crimes contre l'humanité à la cour
pénale internationale à la haye
[Applaudissements]
car il ne s'agit pas d'une guerre contre
l'ukraine seulement c'est une guerre
contre le monde libre et démocratique
nous devons défendre l'ukraine ce n'est
pas un choix c'est une obligation morale
le canada a été le premier pays à
reconnaître l'indépendance de l'ukraine
de l'union soviétique il est maintenant
temps de joindre le geste à la parole
nous devons faire davantage avec nos
alliés pour assurer l'espace aérien de
l'ukraine
[Applaudissements]
nous devons protéger au minimum l'espace
aérien au dessus des corridors
humanitaires
les ukrainiens puisse
s'éloigner des zones de guerre en toute
sécurité et afin que les aides
humanitaires puissent atteindre des
régions à cg et le canada doit faire
tout ce qu'il peut pour
alléger des tracasseries administratives
pour accueillir les écrits ni en fuite
bien que nous savons que bien entendu
nous voulons avant tout que les
ukrainiens puisse vivre chez eux en
toute sécurité dans ce pays souverain et
pacifique
[Applaudissements]
président il indiqué sachez que le
canada un refuge pour les ukrainiens qui
choisissent de venir ici en attendant la
fin et pendant qu'ils seront au canada
nous prendrons soin de nous leur
offrirons espoir et lorsque le temps
sera venu ils pourront retourner à leur
mère patrie et à leurs familles
l'ukraine c'est ce que nous vous
promettons aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
et au peuple ukrainien je conclue en
disant ce qui suit tout simplement les
canadiens vous appuyez aujourd'hui face
à poutine et ses ambitions
les conservateurs sont unies avec
l'ukraine et nous continuerons de vous
appuyer
jusqu'à la toute fin lorsque vous
pourrez en faire reconstruire vos
maisons et vos communautés votre courage
et votre sens ce face à l'adversité nous
inspire tous ça va étrenner gloire à
l'ukraine gloire aux héros continue de
lutter de croire et d'espérer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame merkel le chef du bloc
québécois monsieur yves françois
blanchet à nous adresser la parole
merci monsieur le président a estimé
collègue monsieur le président à et
surtout monsieur le président
il m'est difficile aujourd'hui de
m'exprimer à de simples mots qui ne
peuvent pas porter ou exprimer toute la
tristesse toute l'indignation toute la
colère que suscite la guerre sale
infligée à votre carnation à votre grand
peuple il m'est difficile d'admettre une
certaine et puis sans souci une
impuissance à faire beaucoup plus qu
exprimer notre compassion notre désir
qui n'est que l'ombre du vôtre de nous
réveiller tous de ce cauchemar qui
habitent nos écrans au quotidien
bien sûr la nation québécoise je crois
pouvoir le dire la nation québécoise et
massivement derrière vous derrière votre
peuple
bien sûr nous avons demandé et soutenons
que le canada agisse de la seule façon
valable en concertation avec les pays
libres du monde et avec les grandes
organisations internationales tant
économique que militaire qu'humanitaire
bien sûr nous appelons aussi à des
sanctions économiques toujours plus
sévères a fait que ce soit de
l'intérieur même de la russie est par la
négociation équilibrée que vienne la fin
de cette agression un sens et
nous insistons auprès du gouvernement
canadien pour que soit allégé les
obstacles à l'accueil de réfugiés
d'origine ukrainienne
temps du québec que le canada il y a des
gens il ya des familles il y à des
ressortissants qui veulent accueillir
ces réfugiés
il faut aussi que soit mise en place une
navette humanitaire entre vote
territoire et les nombres c'est avec
désarroi que nous entendons aussi votre
appel pour davantage d'armes vous y avez
droit vous en avez besoin la nation
québécoise et pacifique la nation
ukrainienne et pacifique je suis
convaincu que c'est à contrecoeur aussi
que vous sollicitez ses armes aux gens
ont le droit de défendre ce qu'ils
aiment ils ont le droit de défendre
cette terre qui est la leur
alors oui monsieur le président un conte
armes les ukrainiens vite et plus
le président a tout ça reste trop peu
trop peu à chaque fois que marc un homme
une femme un enfant chaque fois qu'un
hôpital une garderie un écoles parcs ou
une seule fleur sont détruits chaque
fois monsieur le président à chaque fois
nous crie qu'on en a fait trop peu et
que dans une certaine mesure on l'a fait
trop tard
je ne la crois monsieur le président
qu'il faut distinguer les peuples de
ceux qui les dirigent je plais à croire
que le peuple le peuple russe est la
première victime du dictateur du kremlin
mais il ya des chefs des meneurs désir
qui parle bélier pour leur peuple il ne
fait aucun doute que vous en êtes
vous avez su retourner une des pires
armes de l'ennemi contre lui my man la
puissante la vicieuse la mesquine
machine de duperie et de désinformation
du crèmerie a voulu imposer leur ici
mensonges et d'une histoire écrite par
les dictateurs à son seul profit au
profit de sa seule gloire personnelle
vous avez au contraire
par la simplicité par la franchise par
le courage vous avez forcé la main du
monde entier vous avez maintenu sur
votre peuple le regard de la planète et
ce faisant vous avez su et vous devez
encore insisté pour davantage obtenir
une aide qui peut être autrement vous
aurait échappé
voyez monsieur le président ce que nous
ne pouvons pas faire
est ce qu'il y a le plus cruel
vivre cette guerre vignoble dans dix
sous sol sombre ce coin par le
tremblement des bombes lâchées sur vos
villes et vos villages
ce que vous aimez
douter
futur
appréhender une reconstruction qui
durera au moins une génération
avoir peur
contre la peur au ventre des enfants
duquel nous ne pouvons que trop peu
je vous prie de nous en excuser
le trait nuit monsieur le président n'a
ni le coeur ni le courage ni la force ni
la dignité de vaincre la bravoure du
peuple ukrainien
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président de lens qui vous
avez écrit
la liberté vous sera rendu
et à sa modeste mesure où le québec
célébrera avec l'ukraine merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur blanchet
jeu c'est de la paresse la parole au
leader du nouveau parti démocratique
mais jamais ici merci monsieur le
président
je souhaite remercier le président
céline ce qui nous avons entendu ces
propos aujourd'hui nous le remercions
pour son courage son inspiration pour sa
résilience nous remercions les
ukrainiens également pour leur courage
leur résilience
unsa demandé d'imaginer d'imaginer à
quoi ressemblerait
notre vie de se réveiller le matin
en vivant des bombardements comment
expliquer à nos enfants et comment
expliquer pourquoi nous sommes attaqués
nous a demandé comment une femme en d2
d'imaginer la perte de 97 enfin il nous
a demandé d'imaginer également les
villes de notre grand pays bombardé et
pilonnés
vancouver toronto ottawa montréal et
nous à fait imaginer des chars d'assaut
d'imaginer des bancs de tomber sur nos
écoles de collectivités un pitot
on n'y arrive pas en images seti c'est
inimaginable pour le canada mais nous
avons vu les horreurs qui se déroulant
en ukraine nous avons bien entendu les
mots du président et des esquives et
nous a demandé de partager la la la
peine qu'ils vivent la souffrance
nous sommes de tout coeur avec eux les
gens se préoccupent sont inquiets il
nous a demandé
d'imaginer
tout cela était d une il a reconnu que
le canada est un allié mais ils ne
demandent eux ils nous demandent de
je les canadiens soutiennent l'ukraine
et répondront à l'appel pour fournir
juste à être possible
[Applaudissements]
avantage
aux sanctions sont importantes comme l'a
dit le président céline ce qui il faut
les intensifier nous savons que ce que
nous pouvons faire nous savons que le
président poutine nature des du de son
pays des gens mais ce qui lui apporte
c'est sa richesse et la façon de
s'attaquer à lui de lui faire sentir la
pression c'est de cibler cibler leurs
richesses qui est détenu par ses alliés
sont les oligarques et c'est ce que nous
faisons il faut continuer à appliquer au
lait son sens le plus sévère ciblé le
président poutine et son cercle
nous savons que nous pouvons fournir de
l'aide humanitaire au canada a fait sa
part continuera de le faire il faut
saluer donc et accueillir les ukrainiens
qui cherchent refuge il faut fournir de
l'aide humanitaire sur le terrain il
faut continuer à fournir ce soutien
présidence qui a demandé si on peut
imaginer l'horreur de cette guerre il a
demandé si on peut imaginer les mêmes
gars se réduisent ici au canada et c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne peut pas imaginer
et il a demandé qu'on augmente l'aide et
nous devons augmenter l'aide à d'ukraine
ont été bons augmenter les sanctions
nous devons répondre
elle a besoin des ukrainiens et on veut
et on va le faire
affi kebab
je pense aux paroles du président céline
ski du discours qu'il a prononcé je
pense au courage que nous avons observés
tous les jours les ukrainiens qui
défie cette agression l'agression du
président poutine une chose que nous
dénonçons nous observons beaucoup de
courage j'ai du mal à trouver les mots
pour décrire pour ma mère m'a toujours
dit et elle fera dans kujabi charles
nicolas use et oui j'ai toujours mal
compris et elle me disait que ça
signifie d'élever nos esprits
face à l'adversité aux difficultés et ça
m'a rappelé les paroles de ma mère le
courage du président des ukrainiens je
ne peux penser à autre chose que ce que
me dira ma mère il faut défier à
l'adversité et c'est ce que font les
ukrainiens et disent qu'ils n'ont pas
renoncé et c'est très inspirant nous
sommes inspirés par leurs luttes pour la
démocratie la liberté nous sommes en
toute solidarité avec eux il élève nos
esprits et nous serons avec eux jusqu'au
bout
mr thing
la leader du parti vert la dame lcb
tenait à prendre la parole merci
présidentielle inscrit qu'à la leur pour
moi de prendre la parole en ces moments
extraordinaires historique
et pour tous mais mes chers collègues si
nous sommes punis
comme le ver ici au canada nous sommes
partis d'une grande famille vert partout
au monde et 1,80 il demande il ya
quelques jours et j'ai reçu cette lettre
envoyée par le président du parti vert
tu traînes têtards et quant aux noces et
je suit de france chers amis verts
vous écrivant depuis des
abris anti bandes depuis notre ukraine
natale et qui est impitoyablement
attaque est bombardée par les forces
russes depuis ce jour fatidique 24
février de l'élevage de les ukrainiens
sont frapper sans discernement les
dommages collatéraux s'élève à la
destruction totale des villes de
nombreuses infrastructures civiles et
sociales n'ont aucune pertinence pour
les militaires sont elles sont détruites
des milliers de civils sont morts
blessés des millions de personnes fuient
leurs maisons
les volontaires de l'armée ukrainienne
et de la défense civile ont pris les
armes et se battre pour la survie de
l'ukraine ils y perdent parviennent dans
une large mesure mais les attaques
aériennes et aux missiles et des bombes
cause de gros dégâts nous sommes
impuissants nous n'avons pas d'armes
pour contrer les attaques aériennes
nous vous demandons de nous soutenir
exhorté votre gouvernement de t&d à
protéger nos cieux en créant une envie
une zone d'exclusion aérienne
pour résoudre ce conflit pour un monde
fondé sur des règles a dit l'ukraine
simple me brise le coeur
de m'adresser à mon ami a en ukraine
et de lui dire qu'une zone d'exclusion
aérienne risquerait une gare plus large
et même une guerre nucléaire nous quand
nous savons que ces raisons sont solides
elles sont creuses à la fois mais nous
devons utiliser tous les outils à notre
disposition mais il semblerait que c'est
inadéquat le présent céline ski on ne
peut pas vous laisser tomber l'union
craignant que nous devons vous laisser
tomber mais nous trouverons et nous
aurons recours à tous les moyens et
lorsque ces moyens ne sont pas des quoi
nous allait vendre est nous les
inventeront en 56 lors de la crise de
suez
[Applaudissements]
en 56 à suez la stupéfaction un canadien
on s'aime bien au canada
email ou sur le pays avec peu
d'importance du point de vue la
géopolitique mais parfois on a des bons
ici et là des pucelles à éviter les
gardiens de la paix les casques bleus et
il faut un lion que mobiliser cette
ressource pour ce fils poutine il faut
se prévaloir de toutes les idées il faut
se mobiliser pour stopper cette guerre
nous avons vu donc de nombreuses gares
illégal lancées par des superpuissances
est basée sur des mensonges en vietnam
en afghanistan en irak et non il il faut
il faut arrêter les bombardements
il faut avoir un cessez le feu et il
faut faire en sorte d'asseoir bladimir
poutine à la table des négociations et
de trouver une solution pour la paix
et il faut l'arrêter avec la vérité avec
le courage des ukrainiens avec
cette
réalité si atroce et et j'exhorte les
démocrates du monde entier
vous avez beaucoup de courage vous avez
vous nous avez tous un coup inspiré on
ne peut vous laisser tomber parce que
vous ne le ferez pas nous devons faire
davantage nous le savons et comme l'a
dit notre premier ministre vous êtes un
champion de la démocratie et il faut
être digne de jours et il faut faire en
sorte de vous appuyer non arrêtons ces
pertes de vies arrêtant
[Musique]
donc stoppons les plats redémarre russe
qui pleurent leurs soldats et pensons
aux russes qui s'opposent à la guerre et
qui se retrouve en prison disons non à
la guerre
et je conclurai
avec ceux ci je prie je prie pour vous
constamment et je prie pour l'ukraine et
je souhaite que vous veniez ici en
personne bien et qu'on vous invite et
que nous voyons en chair et en os le
président d'un pays en paix de payer
libre et démocratique un groupe un prix
à payer victorieuse nous souhaitons vous
inviter lorsque l'ukraine sera
victorieuse vous êtes l'ami l'ami de
tous les canadiens merci
[Applaudissements]
you must mais merci madame
x son excellence le président de lens
qui de nous avoir adressé la parole je
sais que nous nous souviendrons
longtemps de cet homme exceptionnel
remercie tous les parlementaires du
stick gauche cassé tous nos amis invités
d'avoir participé en personne au par
lien vidéo
c'est à cet événement
il s'agit d'un événement historique que
nous avons vécu ensemble merci jack who
[Applaudissements]
alors encore une fois des
applaudissements extrêmement nourris à
la suite de ces allocutions qui ont été
prononcées cette fois-ci par les
différents chefs des partis d'opposition
des discours parfois très émouvant comme
celui de madame may chef du parti vert
qui a conclu cette série de discours je
retourne à mes invités alors avec moi
louis blouin mon collègue que je
retrouve un ottawa et de mener car elle
qui est politologue et un expert de
l'ukraine au 6 mai merci encore monsieur
d'être avec moi à ce moment ci monsieur
rl je commençais avec vous il y avait
beaucoup d'émotion c'est très très
sentie est-ce que des discours qui vous
ont marqué plus que d'autres dans tout
ce qu'on a entendu l'écouté se s'étaient
tous deux très très bon discours
peut-être au niveau de ce qu'ils me le
discours de madame mais à la fin
évidemment joue beaucoup sur ma faim le
personnel les les émotions la lettre
qu'elle a reçu le de son collègue du
parti vert d'ukraine on voyait sa voix
brisée par l'émotion
et peut-être qui ce que je retiens et
beaucoup de choses que j'ai retenu
maintenant discours de monsieur blanchet
lorsqu'il parle de la façon dont hélène
ce qui est parvenu à retourner larmes
russe qui nous fait si peur depuis
plusieurs années et là on parle pas de
lance de lance-missiles d'un mental de
larmes de la désinformation
et lorsque monsieur trudeau dans son
allocution au tout début parler de
monsieur linh skill comme un champion de
la démocratie ce qui a mené à une
ovation de nos deux minutes c'est le
lien en fait avec ce que les démocraties
au canada et ailleurs vivre depuis
plusieurs années avec le mouvement
tremblay mouvement populiste la
désinformation pendant la coved
l'ukraine c'est une démocratie aussi la
seule en fait dans cette région là et ça
c'est une démocratie lorsque
zelensky nous dit
nous appelle nous les canadiens des amis
de la vérité mais ça va nous chercher
c'est la vérité c'est ce qu'on voit pas
la télévision russe mais on voit sur
toutes les chaînes de télévision au
monde sait c'est ce que nous dit
zelensky et la vérité c'est un peuple
qui littéralement se bat pour sa survie
la survie de son état dans une unité
dans un élan comme ça qui est qui est
extrêmement
émouvant et inspirant c'est
effectivement beaucoup d'émotion parce
qu'on parle d'une réalité comme vous
dites qu'on voit devant nos yeux jour
après jour avec la couverture
journalistique avec ces images aussi qui
se promène sur les réseaux sociaux et
avec tous ces témoignages parce que
beaucoup de gens aussi mais là je parle
pour les réseaux français évidemment qui
nous ont accordé des entrevues en
français d'ailleurs ça étonne beaucoup
de nos téléspectateurs monsieur harel le
plat que vous savez la réponse à ce
niveau là il ya beaucoup de gens en
ukraine qui parlent français
oui il faudrait peut-être entre autres
salué l'initiative de nos cousins c'est
à dire la france et qui a un réseau
exceptionnel à travers le monde mais
aussi en ukraine d'institutions
culturelles qui inclut évidemment des
des écoles la fin des cours pour
apprendre le français c'est comme ça que
les beaucoup de d'ukrainiens ont appris
le français en fait moi quand je
commence quand j'ai commencé avec mes
collègues français participer et
organiser des écoles d'été c'est est
financé par l'ambassade de france en
ukraine avec l'institut français y avait
tout le côté francophile et on le voi on
le voit maintenant direct avec des
témoignages dans notre langue et cette
force d'autant plus grand de le fait
qu'on partage à ce moment là la même
langue donc les témoignages sont encore
plus frappant le phénomène
d'identification en réalité devient très
très fort oui je retournerais vous sur
le plan politique maintenant avec le
positionnement de nos partis d'eux nos
positions ici on va quand même qu'avec
certaines différences dans les nuances
dans les discours qu est ce qui nous
effraie fait où est la solidarité elle
était à l'unisson là bien entendu mais
effectivement il ya une chose que je
note en particulier c'est madame bergen
la chef intérimaire du parti
conservateur qui a dit sauf erreur pour
la première fois que le parti
conservateur était en faveur d'une
exclusion aérienne donc une protection
du ciel de l'ukraine en tout cas pour ce
qui a trait aux corridors humanitaires
donc que l'on prévoit une exclusion
aérienne pour certaines ondes pour
permettre justement l'acheminement de
denrées aux besoins l'évacuation de juin
ou si heureux c'est nécessaire alors
madame bergen qui va un petit peu plus
loin parce que jusqu'ici le gouvernement
trudeau dit écoutez on ne veut pas
franchir cette ligne là ils ont peur de
l'escaladé ils ont peur d'emmener au
troisième conflit mondial est ce que
cette position là pour échanger monsieur
à rennes le faisait bien changé il ya
plein de choses je le faisais bien
marqué du dollar il ya plein de choses
qu'on imaginait impossible il ya
quelques semaines à peine alors on verra
bien là dessus mais madame joly nous a
dit tantôt qu'on était pas n'a pas non
plus pour l'adhésion de l'otan de
l'ukraine à l'otan alors ça c'est une
chose que je remarque est entendue aussi
le chef bloquiste monsieur blanchette
qui a tenu à souligner que la nation
québécoise spécifiquement était derrière
les ukrainiens monsieur singh lui jon
peddie qui a essayé de reprendre peu
cette manière de faire de monsieur
zelensky dans son discours il faut se
mettre dans les souliers des ukrainiens
actuellement comprend ce que ce qu'ils
vivent lui aussi voulait marquer les
esprits de cette manière-là et
évidemment ce discours très marquant
aussi de la représentante du parti vert
elizabeth may qui est aussi vraiment
avait tout à emmagasiner cette douleur
on le voyait bien qui a essayé de
l'exprimer cas sans doute été je pense
la plus émue elle pleurait à certains
moments pendant ce discours a aussi
loué à le souligner l'impuissance et je
suis désolé mais à cette demande
d'exclusion aérienne en fait ça c'était
sa position aussi a dit nous devons nous
dire non et y est et on la sentait
contre et on la santé oms en teck c'est
douloureux pour elle d'abord à lire cela
il faut qu'on prend ce jeudi que tous
ses députés députés et sénateurs qui
étaient là aujourd'hui ils reçoivent une
tonne de courriels de lettres de
canadiens d'origine ukrainienne mais
aussi le canadien de manière générale
qui veulent aider qui veulent ensemble
qui veulent en faire plus qui veulent
pouvoir accueillir des gens le plus
rapidement possible alors la pression
sur les parlementaires canadiens elle
est très très élevé également monsieur
harel dans ce que monsieur blanchet du
chef que chef du bloc québécois a dit
est quelque chose qui m'a frappé aussi
il dit j'espère que les sanctions
économiques vont avoir un tel effet qui
va y avoir une pression allait terne au
sein même de la russie pour forcer
monsieur poutine a arrêté est-ce que ça
effectivement
on commence à le sentir vous avez vu
hier ce geste tellement audacieux là
d'une réalisatrice et productrice le
russe qui risque elle risque la suite de
sa vie en brandissant cette pancarte en
disant nous dans les médias on vous ment
il ya une guerre actuellement en ukraine
les russes sont derrière ça est ce que
vous sentez que c'est un mouvement qui
est grandissant au sein de la russie
écoutez il faut saluer son courage inouï
elle risque carrément là avec la
nouvelle loi 15 ans de prison pour ce
simple geste
et hiop il ya des manifestations qui
sont réprimées à chaque fin de semaine
il y a une très très forte répression
russie est-ce que ça va influencer
encore une fois le président poutine qui
essentiellement pour pratiquement
absolue le nom d'un système politique
russe
ça reste à voir ça reste à voir
si il fallait que le régime commence à
craquer ce n'est pas l'impression que ça
va venir d'abord c'est à dire de la rue
ou des eaux du courage la
2d russe mais plutôt d'en haut des
services de sécurité parce que le
système politique russe c'est un système
essentiellement de cette une alliance
entre l'armée et la police surtout la
police puisque poutine lui-même venait
de la police secrète de l'air ce qu'on
appelle kgb à l'époque c'est à ce moment
là mais encore une fois il faut pas se
faire d'illusions c'est un régime qui
est très très très fort alain terme en
fait qui le niveau de contrôle
actuellement commence de plus en plus à
ressembler au système soviétique
des pires années les pires années en
termes encore une fois de répression on
vient de signer une dépêche vous la lie
en direct la sept protestataires dont on
vient de parler le cas eu ce geste
d'éclat la télé a été condamné une
demande libéré parce que vous savez on
était sans nouvelles d'elle et les gens
la chercheuse demander où est ce qu'elle
est rendu alors libéré on verra la suite
ça veut pas dire qu'ils avaient échappé
à long terme le à une peine de prison on
verra sireuil procès enfin on va voir
comment les choses vont se développer un
monde l'a fait il nous reste une minute
à peine me suis à rennes avez vous
l'impression c'est mission accomplie
quand même le pour cette première
portion de la journée parce
qu'évidemment ça va se décliner avec
d'autres réactions dans les heures qui
vont suivre mais pour l'instant pour
monsieur et ce qu'est ce que c'est
mission accomplie avec cette allocution
au canada je crois que oui évidemment il
vient nous chercher au niveau des
émotions et quand monsieur singh jean
allait faut s'élever dans l'adversité
comme sa mère lui disait cela il faut
que nous élever nos esprits dans
l'adversité mais aussi au niveau
politique on voit les cinq chefs de
leurs positions qui essentielle ment son
demande tous au gouvernement
il faut en faire plus il faut en faire
plus donc le gouvernement est sous
pression d'enfer encore plus d'être
créatifs comme madame mais le souligner
mots de la faire quelques secondes oui
mais je pense que monsieur trudeau lui a
rappelé aussi son objectif politique
c'est de montrer qu'il est au devant de
cette crise qu'il est un acteur clé ça
c'est certain mais en même temps le
revers de ça c'est qu'il fait monter les
attentes quand le président ukrainien et
bien la chambre comme ça et répète
toutes ses demandes sur pour l'otan
notamment alentours monsieur trudeau
c'est clair que ça représente une
certaine pression sur lui pour continuer
de mener la charge mais dans le coffre à
outils des sanctions canadiennes les
commence à être pas mal vie de julie
parce que tellement de choses qui ont
été annoncées ces derniers jours alors
lui le défi c'est de continuer à montrer
qu'il peut montrer la voie de ses alliés
ce jour merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui pour vivre ce moment
très solennel le moment est historique
réellement avec cette allocution du
président hélène ski président craignant
au canada 2 mai car elle merci louis
blues merci beaucoup dans un instant on
va passer assez basse est mauvaise et
mordus de politique et on va vous
laisser sur ces images la chambre des
communes où les députés ont longuement
applaudi le président ukrainien une fois
son allocution terminée alors si vous
voulez d'autres nouvelles aussi c'est
sur le site de radio canada.ca barres
obliques ukraine ont tous nos dossiers
sont là dessus merci d'avoir été avec
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]